as you probably know rudy giuliani has
been suspended from the practice of law
indefinitely and he may be disbarred
soon
but what's going to happen now and can
he still practice
well i was curious about that so i
looked it up a lot of people thought he
was only barred in new york that's not
actually true
rudy giuliani is also barred in the
district of columbia
side note this is important because he
filed an affidavit in one of the
election-related cases where he said
that he was a member of good standing of
the dc bar
in fact he hadn't been paying his dues
so he was not in fact in good standing
people were wondering whether that meant
that he had perjured himself in those
election cases
but the more important point is that now
that he's been suspended in new york
according to the dc bar rules he has an
affirmative obligation to notify
dc about the suspension and presumably
dc will issue a reciprocal suspension
against
giuliani so he's not going to be able to
practice in new york he's not going to
be able to practice in dc
and we're not going to see rudy giuliani
in court anytime soon